all right christian here we are in the
parking garage across from resorts world
and it's a very exciting time with one
month
left to go we want to give you a look
that you can't see from the road folks
here
it's a gorgeous sophisticated property
we haven't been allowed inside just yet
but we did catch up with resorts world
president scott sabella who says
everything is moving full steam ahead on
a property that he says will incorporate
some of its earlier las vegas history
i was raised in this town and my first
job was one was at the stardust
so i was a busboy here
fast forward some four decades and now
steve savella is the resort's world
president
this brand new hotel casino which graces
the 87 acres where the stardust and
westward hoe used to sit
it's massive it features 3 500 rooms
more than 40 food and beverage spots
250 000 square feet of meeting space 117
000 square feet of casino space scott is
really proud of the property
it's very state of the art and he
promises it'll be great for visitors and
locals alike
i want to bring back old las vegas you
know i want it to be all about the
employees and the guests
we don't have a big corporation that we
report to we have our
our support over malaysia but it's me
and my team so
we're going to set the tone and create
the culture here and i think
it's old las vegas what i grew up with
it's not so cool there's going to be
some way newton tribute some elvis
things throughout a cool art program
van gogh paintings and sculptures placed
throughout and a lot of
must-see instagram moments and of course
don't forget
this will be the first property to
connect with the convention center
and the people mover project as well
reporting live i'm kirsten joyce